what's happening reject nation I'm Greg
album and I'm Jean Humphrey so uh this
video today is just going to focus on
one movie news story where it made me
contemplate maybe I should have called
this video
hashtag conflicted because as a new
segment hashtag hashtag conflict if you
guys haven't heard mark hamill the guy
who plays the Joker and the Batman
animated series it's always known for
really and Ryan Johnson you know yeah
the rock Brian Johnson and Mark Hamill
they put up his tweet Brian Johnson more
stuff is coming that's the nature of the
beast what I fully endorse avoiding
everything you can from now till
December and Mark Hamill responded back
to us saying I fully endorsed this Rian
Johnson endorsement avoid everything you
can from now until December and if you
look more to the tweets basically what
they're saying is like the marketing
department for the next Star Wars movie
that are suggesting avoid the trailers
avoid the clips avoid everything because
this movie will be a better experience
if you don't know jack there's probably
a lot to be revealed in the trailers as
we know how trailers do especially this
channel will know the reason why it's
conflicting obviously it's conflicting
because I don't know super anal about my
movie going experience I really am if
you know me I'm like dead center that's
what matters even if we have to be like
a little close to the screen I want to
be in the center so I have a perfect
ratio looking you'd spread it you know a
lot of people will be asked to rearrange
if it turns out actually the wrong
center yes all my friends were next to
me like these are your phones off your
phone I make sure my friends phones are
off and beyond having an anal
movie-going experience I'm very
particular to on when I'm watching on
not having a lot ruin for me it bothers
me you know and for a channel like ours
yeah yeah we do a lot of commentary
let's get real most of our views come
from reactions I feel like for anybody
who wants to be even somewhat of a
cinephile like that's kind of part of
the package yes you want the movie going
experience to be sort of sacred you want
the movie to be allowed to speak for
itself on a don't
the complete yet you know you don't want
too much stuff infecting your mind
infecting the way that you think and
watch the movie during like I'm with
John these are all true statements from
Humphrey and Rian Johnson being the
director of the next Star Wars movie in
for Mark Hamill Luke Skywalker himself
to both be upfront and say do your best
to avoid the trailers everything hey I
mean like yeah shower doesn't need more
trailers just you know like let us know
when the movies coming in or taking
marker calendar it'll be a while before
Star Wars really needs true yeah exactly
you see the thing is if I watch these
Star Wars trailers and like I watch all
them and the thing is I'm going to I
mean it's just what the real rejects is
and I honor all whatever reality of our
work whatever whatever is primarily
being requested I'm going to do whether
it's talk about something or react to
something I'm going to do it because
that's part of running a YouTube channel
is you got to honor the subscribers
request at the end of the day I know
that whenever a starburst thing drops
I'm going to get much auricular you
gotta get a star yeah yeah have to this
is Rian Johnson and Mark Hamill these
two people say not to do it so the
conflicting part is met now I'm kind of
worried about watching the trailers and
stuff and the clips or whatever they
release because if they're saying that
that makes me worried like am I gonna
get too much ruin for me I mean what do
I do people Oh
my world is so hard Denise is kind of
harsh let's give her a couple days ago
but but did this tweet like this this
tweet that Ryan Johnson put up was it
prompted by anything or did he just show
up as like you know there's going to be
more stuff don't want to chose that's
what I don't know I don't know if he
already saw trailers and there's already
plenty ruin in the trailers like he saw
to the goddess's of setting because a
marketing department and Ryan's off and
making a film or two very different
departments and when it comes to the
filmmaking in the promotion I would be
sort of shocked if they gave anything
huge away but I'm sure that there would
be you know surprises and things that
you would want to remain special exactly
and the other thing too is people
through these like Star Wars analysis
videos when I watched like Star Wars
stuff I'm not the most Star Wars heavy
knowledgeable dude out there I've seen
every film a few times
I don't watch like the TV shows and
or like go into the books baby expanded
parts of the can I'm not too concerned
on my end
yeah watching all this stuff and being
like I figured it out I figured out the
whole movie there's no kidding yeah I
know I know all the answers now because
I've seen all the trailers I'm not the
smartest guy when it comes to those
things but I also know about a thing
called YouTube comment and this channel
we're the only ones who run it we have
to check the comments and a lot of the
times people are going to leave their
analysis and their theories and being
like tears with the trailer spoiled and
a lot I was right when they put it down
there yeah it just bums me I have to be
like man I wish I didn't even have that
thought going into the movie yeah people
who are invested in swords like they
have theirs and their networks of
information they can access and bring
you answers and yeah a lot of the time
I'm confident that even if it's not you
know the spoiler it's probably close to
this and I love both these guys so I
want to be on their side I want to be on
their fighting side as a movie fan and a
movie fan I'm like yeah I'm going to
avoid just as movie fans don't really
feel like we need a more gonna see this
movie yeah and there's a certain magic
in a certain event even if you don't
love the Star Wars there's a certain
like whoa like a hush that comes with a
Star Wars movie having out so and it
gets you curious to know what they're
doing with the trailers if Rian Johnson
Mark Hamill did see the trailers of the
marketing because when I saw the force
awakens phrase I don't feel like they
give away anything yeah I'm like what
really did they give away the things
that we already knew that like Han Solo
is going to be back in and the
Millennium Falcon will return like
there's all things that we already knew
prior or is like rides awesome thinking
we already know too much too has tech
that will tamper with the movie-going
experience so on there is a huge machine
that surrounds these movies beyond just
marketing you do have news and analysis
and set reports and you know picture
athletes and the interviews that you
never know what the actors are going to
be asked and sometimes it revealed more
information that maybe they were
planning on yeah there's so much access
to the behind the scenes in the
construction of the movie and it's you
know it kind of roads a magical of a
movie
and then and then on top of that you get
a bunch of trailers with a bunch of
footage in the AK and start piecing
things together and yeah at a certain
point you do to sort of want to step
back and enjoy the movie
yeah because as grateful as I am that
this channel is primarily private off of
a trailer reactions and reviews I'm like
ah this is why I'm hashtag conflicted
because I want to just side with them
but I know me and I'm probably going to
end up just watching them reelers anyway
we're in an ad pocalypse people we need
each other oh man I'm curious to know
where you guys stand on this did you
guys hear about Rupp the director and
the star of the movie putting these
statements out there are you going to
actively avoid watching the trailers I'd
be crazy to to see like the trailers are
not getting anywhere near 50% drop off
it was my job everywhere actively
avoiding this this will change marketing
forever yeah no marketing no marketing
anymore people are against it anyone so
where do you guys stand on it are you
brought yeah I know that most of you
will probably still check it out but I'm
curious to hear that from the people who
are not we're going to intentionally go
yeah I know it's out there I'm not going
to check it out yeah one just you know
as moviegoers do you guys feel that
sometimes you know there's too much
footage before the movie or yeah are you
in love with the width they roll this
stuff out now like you do get a lot and
it does kind of feel like a treat in
some ways let us know what you think let
us know what you think a you can
subscribe to the reel rejects can click
that notification bell dad John Humphrey
on Twitter and in Sicilia and also check
out our patreon for exclusive perks and
rewards it's so much fun of a paha
hooray